outcast is directed by Nicholas Powell
and stars Hayden Christensen and Nicolas
Cage and is currently available on VOD
platforms like YouTube and iTunes that
should tell you everything you need to
know in one sentence the movie about an
evil prince who kills his father and
then blames that murder on someone else
and sends all of his men after that
person that person just happens to be a
young boy and a girl Hayden Christensen
is the awesome guy who comes in to save
them and Nicolas Cage is the guy who
trained Hayden Christensen in battle
despite the fact that Nicolas Cage was
in my least favorite movie of last year
left behind I still love the guy he has
given so many good performances and so
many crazily over-the-top and hilarious
and awesome performances that I am
actually excited to see a movie with him
in it and his scenes in this movie are
by far the best unfortunately it's best
in a different way she's good with it on
a yeah but at one time chanoh most
beautiful singing voice but that gods
cut out her tongue
I did my right eye and I found myself
begging for him to come on screen in
this movie because whenever he's on the
screen the movie improves immensely
because unlike Left Behind this is a
crazy over-the-top Nicolas Cage
performance that's absolutely amazingly
awesome there's just not enough of a
minute because he's really only in this
movie for maybe like 20 minutes to a
half an hour the other hour of the movie
is Hayden Christensen giving an
absolutely lifeless and dull performance
every line out of his mouth feels like
ADR and if you don't know what that is
it's the audio dubbing process after you
film it you realize well I want to
change this voice or get some better
audio here everything he says sounds
like that it's like this deep strange
accent that reminded me of the after
earth accents that Jaden and Will Smith
had so what happened to you boy ghosts
bandits but all of this could maybe be
dealt with and sort of accepted in a
b-movie sense if the action was filmed
and choreographed well this movie is
directed by a veteran stunt
this guy's been around the block he
obviously can do great stunt work and
coordinate very good stunt work he's
worked on The Last Samurai in the Bourne
Identity in all tons of movies which I
commend him for immensely but similar to
Left Behind another movie directed by a
stuntman this movie has no real sense of
how to frame a shot it is filled with
ugly dutch angles that reminded me of
Battlefield Earth and more
incomprehensible editing high frame rate
shaky cam where you cannot tell what's
going on the technique it's been
plaguing action movies for years now so
you can't quite enjoy the movie as a so
bad that it's good be movie or as a
hilarious 'ti as I've coined them a
movie that's such an atrocity they're
hilarious speaking of that my Batman and
Robin hilarity is coming up very soon
there's also not enough Nicolas Cage in
the movie being Nicolas Cage to warrant
that title there's just a whole bunch of
horrific li acted cheesy drama and you
can't quite enjoy the movie on that
level because it's just all awful
Nicolas Cage is in the movie for like
the first ten minutes and then he's gone
until around like the 45 minute mark and
he shows up for two shots in a flashback
and then he finally comes back into the
movie an hour in so for going into this
movie expecting some awesome Nicolas
Cage you're not going to get that much
of it that being said he does have some
amazing lines in this movie the simple
man easily bedazzled by Swift talking
young princes Hayden Christensen's
character is continually referred to as
the white devil and yet everyone in the
movie speaks English perfectly of course
because who wants to read subtitles
there really is no reason you should
watch this movie it's not even good in a
b-movie sense the action is truly
atrocious the acting is equally
atrocious I'm going to give Outkast and
F are you really that surprised look at
the cover of this movie look at that
thing
tell me if you're surprised I gave it an
F guys if you want to see Outkast it is
available online legally at places like
YouTube and iTunes check that out if you
want to I guess but don't guys thank you
very very much as always for watching I
really do appreciate it and as always if
you liked this you can click right here
and get stuck mine eyes